es ist immer noch ein großes rätsel wie
konnten die menschen die pyramiden
errichten so ganz ohne bagger kräne und
andere maschinen eine frage die bis
heute nicht endgültig geklärt werden
konnte wurde eine externe rampe
eingesetzt waren es spezialmaschinen
oder sind etwa doch außerirdische die
urheber der pyramiden jetzt hat ein
archäologie team in luxor hinweise im
wüstensand gefunden die dieses rätsel
endlich lüften könnten alle wirklich
spannenden infos dazu bekommt er jetzt
mal klick zum science fiction hier gibt
es täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
kein video herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
selbst heute wäre der bau einer pyramide
ein wahnsinniges unterfangen 2,6
millionen steinblöcke mit jeweils einem
mindestgewicht von zweieinhalb tonnen
pro block müssten herangeschafft werden
mehr als ein halbes jahrzehnt wären wohl
bauunternehmer damit beschäftigt umso
erstaunlicher wie die menschen vor rund
4500 jahren diesem monumentalen bauten
erschaffen konnten
fest steht nur dass die pyramiden extrem
genau gebaut worden sind ungeklärt ist
aber dennoch so vieles warum genau
wurden sie errichtet und wie wurden die
schweren steinblöcke transportiert und
eingebaut in den 70er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts spekulierte der autor erich
von däniken das wohl außerirdische dafür
verantwortlich sein
andere theorien gehen aber davon aus
dass die alten ägypter spezialmaschinen
eingesetzt hatten oder aber eine äußere
rampe in den vergangenen jahren fanden
forschungsteams immer mal wieder
hinweise auf die bautechniken mit denen
zumindest die jüngeren pyramiden
errichtet worden sein könnten
einige indizien lassen rückschlüsse
darauf zu dass tatsächlich riesige
rampen benutzt worden sind damit könnten
die gigantischen steine aus kalkstein
oder gar nicht immer höher
an die spitze der pyramiden geschoben
beziehungsweise gezogen werden und diese
theorie wird wohl immer wahrscheinlicher
denn jetzt hat ein internationales
forschungsteam tatsächlich einen fund
gemacht der diesen ansatz bestätigt
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler fanden in der nähe des
ägyptischen hartmut nördlich von luxor
die reste einer ansteigenden rampe an
ihren seiten befinden sich zwei treppen
mit einer steigung von bis zu 20
an ihnen pfostenlöcher die ihren
verwendungszweck mehr als eindeutig
belegen hier wurden wohl schwere und
große blöcke auf kufen den berg hinauf
transportiert so die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sie sind sich sicher die alten ägypter
haben damals die steine auf solchen
rampen hoch bewegt und zwar mit hilfe
von seilen und einer art schlitten dabei
wurden die seile um pfosten herum nach
unten umgelenkt so dass die arbeiter
darüber die blöcke nach oben zogen also
nach unten ziehen über den pfosten und
dann die umlenkung über die pfosten
machte es eben möglich die rampe selbst
stammt den angaben des forschungsteams
wohl aus der zeit zwischen 2650 und 2580
vor christus und ist äußerst gut
erhalten damals reagierte jobs der
erbauer der berühmten schiffs pyramide
von gizeh die eines der sieben
weltwunder der antike ist dazu roland n
marge von der university of liverpool
damit liefert die rampe auch
unschätzbare einblick geben die logistik
und die techniken die nötig waren um die
cheops pyramide zu errichten
auch felsgravuren und andere bildliche
darstellung untermauern diese neue alte
theorie
übrigens haben wir darüber zuerst auf
dem englischen kanal von 520 fiction
berichtet wenn also garantiert nichts
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auch
klicks zum science fiction auf englisch
dafür einfach hier klicken
noch mehr rätsel und mythen über die
pyramiden gibt es hier mit legends and
speculation that most exciting pur mit
facts einfach draufklicken ich freue
mich euch auf euch auf dem englischen
kanal zu tun
stay tuned